okay let's get right back to the phones
at 617-830-4750 there
are uh many people who are hoping to
get on the phone let's go to our caller
from the 215 area code who's calling
from 215 today
hi david yeah who's this
uh this is ryan i'm actually calling
from raleigh north carolina
all right and we're not on speakerphone
are we uh no do you need i
i you have my headset and i need to get
out i think it's okay
okay um i just had a quick question
about biden's environmental plan so
as we know he's using the green new deal
as a framework as you said
um and one of the things to my
understanding that he's using
is uh he's including nuclear power
into this into his uh environmental plan
i was kind of hoping to get your idea
or i guess your thoughts on nuclear
power in general and then
how do you think the american people
will think about it so
i like this question because i think
that there is a lot of mis
misinformation and mistaken beliefs
about nuclear among
some on the left who are just
reflexively against it and and often the
reason that people on the left are
against nuclear power
is because they imagined that new
nuclear with modern technology would
have all of the same risks that
existed 40 and 50 years ago with nuclear
which is simply not true
so i actually in principle
don't have a problem with nuclear new
nuclear as a bridge
to getting to alternative energy at some
hopefully defined point in the future i
think that
people on the left who just say it's
unsafe don't understand how dramatically
different
modern nuclear would be and the ways the
technologies that would make
you know a so-called meltdown almost
impossible so that's one piece of it
the problem i have with nuclear is that
it takes a long time to get new nuclear
capacity online
and i question whether
the time it would take to do it would
simply
be a disincentive and would just justify
delaying
getting on clean renewables altogether
um and so that's my question mark i
don't remember how many years it is
that it takes to put new nuclear online
but
i would like to be significantly in the
direction of clean renewables by then
and i wouldn't want the project of doing
new nuclear
to delay uh what what eventually should
be the
the end goal but i think the people who
are just like oh it's just unsafe
we shouldn't do it i'm open to the idea
of nuclear as a bridge but i would want
to be really clear about how do we get
back off of it
yeah no i totally agree with that i'm
actually going for my doctorate in
nuclear engineering so i'm kind of
biased
oh okay well i don't have to tell you
then yeah yeah that's good i i just
wanted to get your take on it and
get your take on how the american people
would kind of feel about it because i'm
definitely
on board for it just because of how our
electoral system works and how
everything's on demand and
you know wind and solar are nice and
stuff but we don't have the
capabilities to store that energy
economically
so you know nuclear is definitely one of
the options to get
on-demand power that's definitely carbon
free yeah i think
we will have i think we will have the
ability as
the energy storage problem i believe is
going to be solved but you're right that
right now it is
it is a problem that we have not yet
solved
okay thanks so much for your tips to get
my call david all right thank you
appreciate the phone call